[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من عجائب جريان وادي الرمه لهذه السنه انه
جرى في عز الشتاء اخر المربعانيه واول
الشبط والمواسم عباره عن سمات مناخيه تحدث
لفتره
تنهض فيها الرياح الماكره التي لا تستقر
على جهه معينه وفي المربعانيه تتحرك فيها
الرياح الشماليه البارده ومع دخول سهيل
تتحرك الرياح الجنوبيه الملطفه والنغمه
المناخيه لا تعزف على وتره واحده بل تنتقل
من وتر الى وتر ثانيه تغيرات سريعه درجه
الحراره تغيرات بطيئه حركه الرياح عندي
ساعات الليالي والايام اعدها ما فات منها
دقيقه قبل كثير من الهوى
نشف ريقه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ونحن الان نعيش في اول موسم الشبط وشباط
يتسموا فيه سرعه التقلبات الجويه ولهذا
اهالينا رحمهم الله يقولون شباط ما على
كلامه رباط وبروده رياحه وتذبذبها وهذه
الرياح البارده يسمونها من بكيه الحصني
وهذا التذبذب يجعل الابواب والنوافذ لها
صوت قرقعه وقالوا شباط مقرقع البيبان
وكذلك هذا التذبذب ويقطع اروقه واحبال
الخيام وقال وشباط
نقطع رباط
[موسيقى]